christophe lui dit tu étais où c'est en
provence au dessus de tout la garde
freinet à flassans c'est un bonne dit
mme ren bungalows numéro 7 pourquoi dans
un petit bar la voûte l'épée ouais c'est
une ancienne bastide tu vois là une
magnifique paire magnifique et dans les
bois tu vas quelques petit à petit
bungalow bah ouais moi la secte toujours
aux boules l'après-midi g3 avec toi j'ai
pas joué parce que quand je te
connaissais tous jouer aux boules que
youtube rd 405 dans l'après midi on
roule tranquille
exact c'est exact mais bon là je vais
attaquer mais le petit le petit concours
redoutent la grand messe des routes me
émond et la nuit tu veux toujours au cap
voilà je vous faut dans ce moment si
j'étais calme et à garder genre 5,6 pas
tous la même chance dans la nuit un
album c'est pas pareil je suis en train
d'être paru album donc je ne m'attends
pas à ses toits mais le disque qui sort
là c'est un extrait d'un album c'est un
extrait de l'album the woman toujours
pas les mêmes rues saint denis
une ou deux fois par semaine aujourd'hui
un vrai je connais tout cela est bien
toujours bien sûr c'est la même c'est
beaucoup dire l'assiette
yatabaré perry fait tâter collection
tâter caisse ouais tu en as combien j'en
ai nov
mais à quoi donc j'ai bon surtout les
américaines j'ai un petit ferrari roger
nordmann j'adore réseau
et puis j'ai d'arles est ce que j'aime
les motos et puis à les petites
anglaises qui sont plus du côté de
véronique marie catherine maurice
pratiques et non lui morgan mg mais tout
ça c'est des années 50 on aime bien les
lire les lignes des années cinquante
sept lits flipper tâter jukebox un
flipper n'ont pas trop où je sais pas
trop si sûr toutefois jeu que de challes
pour la piscine deligny oui je les voir
christophe blain trip hop je voulais un
but rageur c'est pas chez toi lui de la
prime non il est venu voir voir un peu
les machines que j'avais bon j'ai des
machines pas te raconter ce sera pour
noël merveilleux conseil se rapportent
ces trucs quand je suis arrivé ce matin
j'étais des caribous jeudi retrouvez
ouais ben hmida ça fera pas ça me
rapporte des juke-box fait flipper que
tous les échanges m'annoncer vireux non
j'investis beaucoup d'encre surtout dans
le 78 tours parce que tu sais qu'un
disque de billie holiday en ce sens du
tour ça doit quand même pas loin de 500
balles
ouais un miles davis charlie parker
rock'n'roll dit cochrane elvis presley
tout le monde connaît la bretagne etc
c'est que c'est bien
[Musique]
com
chic et
[Musique]
c'est du faux
d'astous
[Musique]
de vous
j'ai cliqué
[Musique]
l'autre
je
semblait que
on égale va bien et qu'elle va bien
cette lutte contre l'échec que j'arrive
il ya un truc dont je tairai parler
quand je vais interviewer la première
fois pour descendre de police et n'avait
pas fait plaisir
qu'est ce que c'était j'ai recommencé
d'abord parce que tu vas dire c'est
michèle torr
il avait fait un enfant michel faure ça
me choque
c'était ma première tournée avec matelas
et tuent les futures tablettes à
recevoir un petit contre si vous avez
des cellules et je n'étais pas fière de
toi quand même c'était pas content non
mais y ait des choses difficiles à
expliquer la ville ayant pas par moi je
vous dis aujourd'hui j'étais la chanson
des matchs rapides de l'accordéon pour
[ __ ] la merde à pizza yvette horner
parce que ouais parce que j'aime bien ce
qu'a fait et puis bah je veux dire je
vais jamais revu michèle torr qui il a
croisé dans quelques attends je vais
pratesi tous les soirs et donc d'en
douter
ouais donc ça lui même et le petit tu
n'as jamais revu non jamais je ne
m'étais jamais eu envie de faire un
métier j'ai commencé j'ai une grande
ville qui à 17 ans le jeu que j'aime
profondément
jour et nuit et qui en ce moment se
branche dans là on n'a rien faire et et
le piano et ouais j'ai pas eu la chance
de passer par là quand je la vois délire
et wade ni better ou chopin c'est un
kiff calibre alors par saâd rue mieux
faire un dix ans tu fais deux sortes de
disque final mentale genre de disque où
aller ou des droits des femmes
ouais ouais tu nous fais le 45 tours tu
savais comment c est câline berger a
pris kalinka vu un procès et jacky
moulières l'épaule ça je savais pas où
aller c'est vrai que ça ressemble à la
roma ouais ça ressemblait vaguement rudd
et une avait pompé ou quoi
aujourd'hui on peut le dire là où sept
et dix ans pour travaux le temps que je
fasse ça capable de faire à linars il
ajouté avec les peuples par aline c'est
l'étude avait vraiment pompes et je me
suis gêné non mais ça s'est arrangé
comment puisque après tu m'as ressorti à
la geronimo regagné tard gagné après
m'en sortir mais je suis quand même tous
les maliens que ouais mais toute l'étude
que tu avais fait avec aline tu es
obligé de filer j'écris molière arracher
ce match et arrêtent leur match avait
aidé avaient garé leur procès il avait
gagné
ouais pourquoi je retouche il est sous
web il a fallu surface de procès dans le
temps ouais je redresse et un travail
tout ça ouais
g
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
je vais comme
[Musique]
les marionnettes bien sûr il ya eu
stéphanie il ya eu un succès fou à
succès pour s'asseoir à côté 45 tu fais
le truc pas mal et des balles en tentant
côté 33 tours est sanef ça c'est autre
chose alors c'est les mots bleus c'est
le nom bizarre avec boulevard des
italiens qui s'engagent alors puisque
24,4 au fond c'est à dire pouvoir d etat
à sa terre de l'album j'avais fait avec
bob decout et alors là tu as les mecs
qui te compare à avancer à bashung enfin
les mais cabaye ont quitté dire sur toi
dans libération c'est l'autre dimension
de christophe c'est le comble c'est
celle qu'on colle un peu moins si je
connais un petit peu moins difficile
d'expliquer que ça fait plaisir
quebéc et des fans qui comprennent
effectivement quand tu écris une chanson
comme merci john d'être venu au mariage
qui viendront m'accorde pas fini
d'écrire un truc comme ça tu es plutôt
fier aux tu vois bon il ya des mecs qui
comprennent pas ça veut pas leur laisser
la vie voilà le dernier la chic chic et
une est dans quelle catégorie c2 bout
d'un album sérieux ou c'est un truc
genre stéphanie à lille marionnettes
succès fou non chic et là c'est mon
petit côté ce que c'est foutu voilà
ticket avec un texte est cassé la voix
et la chanson triste en voilà japonais
s'en sont prises aux canaries et plein
de parisiens va si bien
et puis mais ça si tu veux bon l'album
est automatiquement il a une direction
un peu différente dans le son dans la
composition bon c'est toujours assez
primaire parce qu'en fait je suis
reconnu dans sa formation qui comme
toujours moins de charges mal comme ça
problème et puis c'est surtout la
création de son intéressant fait tu
voilà ce que j'ai fait en provence
ouais j'ai celle d'un studio il ya ma
balle et on a sorti des commandes et des
micros dans les parcs et l'enregistrer
plein de son droit naturel parce que je
pense que son latéral c'est le départ si
tu veux du film pour la musique
habitant à côté
de vivaqua si on leur promet alors à
juvisy-sur-orge des fois ouais ouais ça
me suis toujours un petit pincement
qu'ils comptaient faire un petit peu
mieux mais je vais pas passer des tests
of bonsoir
alors tu sors un double album 23 titre
s'appelle succès fou avec l'éthique du
début c'est-à-dire aline les
marionnettes avec l'époque des albums
les mots bleus señorita tout est bien à
sedan ce disque à part la pochette
l'apache est c'est risqué ouais mais bon
on aime on le prend pour un risque ou
rondes et kiki picasso c'est un truc et
fait aussi un peu
c'est parce qu'annulant le disque
enfin tant que c'est que ça tu t'en fous
toi
non je comprends je suis pas d'accord
mais bon on s'est fait ouais antennes et
à juvisy-sur-orge ton père était
installateur de chauffage central ouais
et elle est étalée sur la côte qu'on
stoppe oui
[Musique]
la grande époque de la côte d'azur entre
64 ouais c'est avec une chanson des
commandes et ça plaît à washington ouais
tu le faisais ça je faisais c'était pas
connu jetait dans les boîtes de nuit
d'abord et après je t'ai dans l'est dans
les pizzas est-ce que c'était pas connu
j'ai écouté ces gens là ouais c'est un
traditionnel ce match est comme ces gens
là sur radio caroline un essai sortie en
france ah non en prêt et voit quand je
chante et ça je disais que c'était moi
qui la composent et plus frais mais bon
c'est super machel page avec 15 ans
alors en 1964 tu vas gens les peintures
rencontre une fille qui s'appelle aline
natta nowitzki était assistante d'un
estomac tôt et qu'il est toujours
écoutée justement chanter il est d'après
pour elle tu as composé à lille 65 tube
énorme
il ya eu un procès quand même avec jacky
molard parce que ça ressemble à une
chanson qui avait je suis sorti en 62
capes et la romance mais ça ressemblait
vraiment ça semblait pas mal
effectivement bon et un procès je les
perds du blocage du carroi s'inquiéter
car ses idées recettes est tout même sa
part rigolé du tout la loi mais suivant
je rencontre j'avais 20 ans je dirais
d'un mois qui sait juste qu'il fallait
partie des sommes qu'il va leur roulotte
dire moi c'est un sacré le danger ma vie
alors 66 te fais les marionnettes 67
monsieur le professeur en fait avait la
haine des tubes on ne sait pas du tout
ce que tu voulais faire toi tu voulais
faire du rock
si vous l'êtes dany baby à l'ailé ou
ligand ouais mais c'est moi je voulais
plus faire du blues
parce que si tu veux ce qui m'a bercé
dans les années 60
quand même au curling king slim harpo où
séjournent à rien est-ce que c'est pas
le fait d'être devenu un tube heures
français par rapport au bout ce que tu
voulais chanter
quitte à donner une espèce de et de
haine de toi et qui t'a amené à faire
toutes ces conneries parce qu'on a fait
après des conneries là partir de 67 non
crochet mullinder nord c'est l'image que
j'ai donné c'est pas de ma faute a fait
comprendre qu'en fait on fait une phase
de presque un garde est nul c'est vrai
qu'avant un gala par jour
le pognon qui arrivait comme pas
possible tu t'achètes un flat avec
terrasse dans le xvième les bolides
enfin tu es parti dans un drôle de trip
un peu un peu pop star se développe la
plus la défense et l'alcool quand même
bien j'y connais depuis paris on commet
trop la défense et s'intéresse à sa
radio h ouais donc effectivement je
pouvais pas beaucoup ce qui est un peu
par la suite nous empêcher de commandos
de décrire et quant au bout d'un an et
demi deux ans je suis là c'est grave
l'ajac moi j'arrive pas à trouver une
idée jebali mais parce qu'on 69 tu t'es
retrouvé ruiné disparu quoi un moment
tel trou noir oui 68-63 se sont plaints
tête j'étais bien j'étais loin de tous
âges étaient lorsque j'étais revenue
dans moins fréquente est revenue en 73
c'était gymnastique je me faire
pardonner je fais de la peinture je suis
sage et là ça fait tous ses albums et
jean michel jarre des sapins merveille
c'est une époque formidable
depuis longtemps donc ce trou noir c'est
a desservi finale
il avait servi à 2 ouais mais tous les
trophées été jusqu'aujourd'hui tous les
tournois de laisser des trous noirs que
je crois pas qu aller oui parce que j'ai
besoin de ça moi je peux pas toujours
pas toujours il faut que je m'arrête
commence à être aimé par la critique à
ce moment là et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui des gens comme comme
bâillon par exemple 10 ya un côté yéyé
pourri chez christophe un peu mencé
bonne image quand même temps un peu
gérard manset ils trouvent ça aller à
bayonne
il est du goût mais je pense que comme
un non moi je pense qu'il met quand même
dans un à l'écart de tout ça je pense
mais le côté yéyé pourri c'est vrai un
peu quand même dans ses albums
ouais peu sournois un peu bizarre bon
c'était le problème de ces albums quand
j'analyse aujourd'hui par rapport à
l'album est en train de faire c'est un
peu le texte est ce que tu en entends
bon je fais un truc tôt merci des
nouvelles venues au mariage
et là j'en suis fier parce que c'est toi
tu l'as mis dans la vieille ville ben
ouais bien sûr mais c'est parce que
c'est tout ce que j'aime j'ai écrit un
truc je me surprends moi même ma famille
señorita les manger le comment moi je
suis un décret nommant ça peut-être pas
être construit le dira peut-être me
prendre pour un large allée jeudi même
si elle interrompt qui m'écoutent moi je
peux écrire des trucs méfiance
[Musique]
dans le microphone pour cent premiers
micro si ian phillips championne ça
quand sonne servient vatan on écoute
avant quand même non il faudrait qu'on
t'aime tout le temps j'ai jamais su
faire semblant
il faudrait qu'on fait tout le temps
[Musique]
et puis ça
toi l'amour c'est le premier des
sacrements
c'est un sacré argument
[Musique]
nireus is de parts ou requin
regard murray
[Musique]
regarde pas
tu dis que tu
il faudra les sifflements salariés
quasi
tu me fais lâcher le volant
et puis j'attends
le paradis
mais rossi
quand on est les noms regard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
c'est vrai
[Musique]
il faudrait
j'ai jamais aimé
da locaux du savant j'apprends
j'apprends mon sperme
pour tout se calme par instants
là que la panique
et c'était ponctuel revient vingt ans et
comme tu le sens philippe sont ils pas
ce type c'est christophe et son trip
faire un boeuf sur le prochain album du
bonhomme dont maintenant mesdames et
messieurs voici le blind test et
érudition émotion une vraie pièce de
collection
après les cartes les boules le billard
et la formule 1 il est très fort dans
son nouveau sport tas dit je fais que je
fais que des 45 parce que c'est les
seuls qui rentre dans les boxes ouais
c'est ça qui fait des 45 matchs et 45
tout ça on va jouer très sûrement si tu
reconnais 10 des autres est ce que tu es
prêt pour le blind pêche
[Musique]
et la vitesse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est à dire pierre sur la chanson ces
mondiaux a classé chanter chanter avec
lui on va aller chanter dans mon grenier
pendant des années à mon piano ouais
t'es tout petits la web si j'ai toujours
à béthune et de chanter ça sur un dix
quinze jours tiens c'était c'était mon
idole avant le blues avant de connaître
si vous leur canon les blues la musique
si tu veux c'est être ça et bratz a
introduit way départ piaf loin cela ça
tu jouais chez toi ah ouais
dans mon grenier social ça à juvisy à
djibouti ces indices de tes parents ça
pas du tout c'est moi qui ai acheté à
ben ouais mais parce qu'elle est sous
terre parce qu'ils aimaient jean rameau
mestrallet se depi sur 7 les sept plaies
mon père n'a jamais été vraiment mais je
m'étais très branché dans la musique
ma mère beaucoup plus ma mère chantait
ma mère chantait comme piaf c'est de là
que tu tiens ces merveilles ma mère
quand elle chantait énervé quand je
chantais la main
mais encore une fois contre cholet
on applaudit pour alors que de plus en
plus
et gagner des titres j'avais un truc sur
leurs terres à t'écouter beaucoup
kosovar de s'écouter techcrunch c'est
vraiment un moment j'ai hésité
mon choix était traduit en traduit ses
copains ouais j'avoue franchement ces
deux génies de génie lui bon et il a
fini plus tôt
et quand tu cette année baby c'est ça
que tu chantais à welch était en fait
jean vincent le crâne sur tes rires
comment j'étais jeune j'aimais côté un
peu imitateurs c'est ce qui me gênait
c'est ce qui m'a gêné le côté jean le
chanteur français qui en tombant dans sa
série gars je sais pas prêts à faire
tout tout tout les chanteurs français
qui retomberait sur certains gars
s'étaient levés dit un truc drôle tu as
dit le rock and roll a disparu en 59
avec l'aileron de l'acadie ouais c'est
vrai parce que je pense vite
merci beaucoup période déjà comment
j'aime y avait eu comme idée à moi mais
ces périodes où j'ai quitté une piste
déjà bon jeu qui frise les trahisons
côté tous les commandes là où les océans
ces listes
[Musique]
s'explique en large pourquoi chercher
des québécois tout est expliqué le
risque vraiment d'argent explique on
perd on passe au suivant
ah bah ça c'est au coeur oui mais non
non non non non
au début j'ai cru que je prends ce qu'on
s'en fait passer mon pti
mais je te dire tu sais pourquoi ces
monteith là je ne sais pas pourquoi
c'est parce que coûte leur proposer
pourquoi j'écoute c'était au coeur parce
que monty qui est un mec qui avaient du
talent est vrai avait pas qu'ils étaient
bien en amont bien vrai et c'est un truc
vraiment à la hauteur et les trucs de au
coeur qu'il avait pompé légèrement enfin
bon ça c'est pas de chance pt c'était
chez qui paye ta guitare c'est qui paye
bout alors un peu à evry baptisera king
qu'est ce qui devenu un mec comme monty
bien conduite et je tenir tout le monde
et il est venu chez moi ya un mois la
branche peu d'aisé nouvelle adresse
que sont ils devenus la c1 il s'est
marié avec une américaine et je crois
qu'il ya grandi avec elle elle est
souvent l'amérique et je crois qu'il est
branché en fait dans les trucs
quand je lui dis je voulais faire un
clip là il me dit écoute je peux
peut-être de faire la synthèse avec
martin scorsese que j'adore avant et
j'ai dit bon ça colle entre nous mais et
c'est bon un trio ne plus jamais chanter
j'y vois plus
voici ce que les guinéens mais dont la
toile un truc je veux pas tromper
laissez-moi attendez je vais pas trouver
le nom parce que il m'échappe de la
mémoire et les mondes juke est toutefois
j'en parle encore lié avec véronique dit
mais qu'est ce qu'ils veulent et moi je
vais t'aider je peux dire ça mais tu
sais ce qui est devenu non la new york
weir et à new york savoir travail dans
la télé way
bon pas me faire faire une entame de
seconde mais bien sûr tout le temps que
tu veux me directeur à temps
alors petit humain parce qu'il y en
aurait
ça va être bon
c'est vraiment là tu vas mourir quand je
vais bien mais chez qui c'est mais
baissé mais pas de me dire je sais qui
c'est bon tu sais que c'est la limite je
préfère même pas qu'une mode histoire
bon j'étais oui pas mal à acheter allez
on continue connaît par coeur et jallet
j'allais dans msci world 40 ans voilà
c'est à dire
[Musique]
ça c'est la salle à
quelqu'un que j'aime bien ça
c'est très le retiens ça a été pas loin
là quand même
merci
daumas et lou reed mais c'est quoi le
groupe le au plat ah bah ça c'est velvet
bravo
[Applaudissements]
pour toi c'est la musique pour moi ouais
vas te plaît sa séquence à minuit
commencé à écouter ça que tu as fait
après le côté un peu y est pourri dans
un mais je l'avais dit en moi et en moi
c'est sais pas pourquoi ça a vendu le
truc après quoi c'est ce qui m'a donné
envie passer aux actes et parolier là
pour l'instant j'ai pas beaucoup ça
n'avance pas ouais ça avance pas j'ai
fait donc il ya un album de 10 chansons
peu près
j'ai écrit un texte et c'est un peu mon
problème musicalement c'est fait alain
il est prévu pour toi la can ben écoute
un châtiment parler un petit problème en
ce qui concerne alain sait que
d'acquitter son appart ya un mois et
demi maintenant et il n'a plus jamais
donné nouvel ajustement tu vas parler
c'est bien parce que j'aimerais que si
nous aussi nous écouter nous et qui nous
appellent parce que bon on l aime
beaucoup et là le coeur serré avec paris
fait du souci à se faire du souci à
l'argon froid qui nous appelleront ça
sera bien plus d'accord ça sera bien où
on essayait agents qui tant attendu
voilà qui le voit il faut qu'ils nous
appellent au suivant hervé
banega alors ouais c'est ça c'est très
fort c'est dommage poursuite n'a pas
trouvé plus que tu trouves ça c'est
vachement dur celui-ci devient mais
j'étais dire c'est dommage mais je suis
j'ai pas trouvé je connais par coeur
non mais tu veux le dire à la fin dit
dont on tue lem alan vega a dégagé la
partie mais il faudrait quand même comme
bowie
ouais ouais c'est vraiment quelqu'un ton
idole j'adore au coeur
[Applaudissements]
à 2 à 3 notes quoi ah bah ouais ouais
ouais bon c'est bien mais tu veux bon
j'achète gibbons j'avais tout mon coeur
tu vois dans les années cinquante huit
soit 101 et au genre 90 tu vois là
l'album qui file un flash c'est au coeur
toi sache qu'ils occuppent savoir ce que
ça m'a fait quand je suis l'acheter au
coeur bat nous a menés jusqu'à d'or mais
je n'avais alors qu'il nous fait d'un
flashback c'est génial alors maintenant
dix mois le mec dont on n'a pas trouvé
le nom là comme ça tu feras un sans
faute et on le laisse se concentrent
laquelle lui et le blouson de cuir et
cheveux comme ça le seul 4e manche les
douilles comme les lions 6 mois avec
l'anr brownie beurre
oliver
ces dernières saisons l'un des mois
bravo cinq ans d'absence
il a choisi dix champs elysées pour
faire son retour à la télévision voici
christophe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
christophe là je vais vous dire vous
avez fait le plus dur une fois vous êtes
assis là dessus après ça va le plus dur
c'est de mon père est plus haut ouais
comment ça va ça paris ça va comme
quelqu'un qui puisse leur papa qui s'est
couché tard et qui le message est clair
la ce matin 8h 9,1 à non non j'ai fait
plutôt ce genre fait 82 soit vingt
quatre années
en effet j'ai fait du découpage 90 du
découpage
oui c'est pour ça que j'ai assez de ce
calibre découpage ces découpages de
cette nuit elle dit quoi la maîtresse a
dépensé
[Applaudissements]
allait elle est d'accord pour que je
fasse partie le mercredi après-midi de
la garderie avec des enfants dans une
bonne nouvelle ça donc pour moi c'est
merveilleux parce que c'est vrai que ce
monde est terrible merci christophe en
tous les cas d'avoir choisi tout le
monde en parle pour votre retour à la
télévision c'était 50 qu'on vous a pas
vu et vous revenez avec un album qui
vient de loin il vient d'où cet album il
vient de d'une sensation de de
déséquilibre qui fait que j'écris des
notes depuis cinq ans depuis que j'ai
terminé l'autre album était aussi un
petit peu en suspension et donc dans ma
suspension quotidienne maison d'où le
titre comme si la terre penchait qui est
pas mal du tout
comme il ya les arpents choix c'est pas
du tout métal et ce très jeune c'est pas
mais tu as du tout ni où ni un symbole
mais ça peut être aussi interprété comme
ça et donc c'est toute petite note que
je prends c'est pour ça que je suis avec
mais avec vous continuez à travailler
tout le temps vous pouvez sans arrêt
dénotant oui je dire papa ce qui se
passe j'aime bien
vous savez comment on fait
voilà donc ça s'appelle comme si la
terre penchait et on écoute le premier
extrait
[Musique]
verser le sang
et
pierre michelot
mais ne
ciel
[Musique]
le chou
samatan
christophe comme si la terre penchait on
va y revenir cet album d'abord on va se
demander d'où venez vous christophe
christophe yann on voit la culotte de la
fille cool
c'est pas mal non moi je viens travail
c'est un travail et amis si sa joie
non ça commence déjà avec un lien à la
copine de corti déjà on sait plus quoi
faire et la cde suis un minimum de
sérieux
excusez-moi j'ai interrompu vrai nom
christophe c'est daniel bevilacqua
et voilà et vous vous êtes appelé
christophe en fait c'est quand vous
étiez adolescent vous adoriez les
bagnoles et votre grand mère vous allez
faire un très beau saint christophe qui
est le patron des conducteurs saint
christophe
oui je suis fait voler et dans une
voiture vous l'avez vu non j'ai plus de
vous et gardez vous a gardé le prénom
donc de christophe vous êtes né en
octobre 45 à juvisy sur orge
vous êtes fils d'un petit entrepreneur
d'origine italienne de domodossola
et comme j'étais petit xavier souvent en
vacances en italie avec vos parents
beaucoup à milan parce que il y avait
une partie de la famille milan puis une
partie à domodossola quoi dans la vie de
famille chez vous quand vous étiez petit
c'était pas très drôle parce que vos
parents sont violés tout le temps mais
ils se parlaient pas ouais donc il ya
une séparation et puis voyez puis voilà
et puis je me suis puisse retrouver
retrouver enfin retrouvé c'est beaucoup
dire mais ailleurs que 1 mais aussi
beaucoup avec ma mère avec qui j'ai
j'adorais être puisqu'elle était
couturière et que j'adorais nager dans
les chiffons et dans les faits les
épingles c'est pour ça que j'étais en
pension parce que c'était insupportable
vie à la maison chez leurs pensions
parce que
parce que je me suis laissé faire du
roman jeu enfin j'avais tendance plutôt
à faire semblant de rentrée le lundi
partir ailleurs dans si vous accompagner
au lycée vous effet dit oui c'est quand
même le dimanche et vous accompagner au
lycée dès qu'ils avaient de le tourner
ou fugué c'est ça oui monsieur s'est
fait gauler hippiques et un jour quoi à
ma mère qui était occupation principale
à l'époque c'était de dessiner des
bagnoles et weygand à cendres ou non
s'il faisait que ça en cours ouais
surtout pendant la prend dans la lah 5e
4e 3e là où je viens je me suis arrêté
là où j'étais au fond de la classe en
fait mais pas pour c'était juste pour
écouter le prof de philo le première
parce que il y avait en fait lui qui
m'intéresse avec l'un qui m'intéressait
ce qui peut paraître étonnant pour l'en
pour un primitif
alors ce plan de la musique vos
premières passions c'est brassens
et puis dans votre grenier sur le piano
vous changez koutché ça
en les
[Musique]
allez c'est la loi
e
vous a marqué ça c'est ce qui m'a donné
envie de jouer sur ce piano qui était
complètement faut effectivement en lui
grenier où on avait créé une boîte pour
les surboums du jeu disney du jeudi
puisque à l'époque c'était le jeudi la
fête et le samedi 15 et dimanche et
lundi et le mardi qu'après le mercredi
et la semaine d'après je vous à ce mets
donc on après on fait la même
appellation musicale pour vous
christophe ça a été le blues avec robert
johnson john lee hooker et un matin
ouais un matin vous tirez vos pompes
parce que vous seriez vachement vos
pompes à l'époque ou cracher dessus
maintenant tout le temps autour d'une
pompe pas mouillé c'est pas une pompe
ciric huawei et à la radio vous entendez
ça
[Musique]
là c'est pas
mais
vous dites quand tu écoutes ça pour la
première fois avec la trézence à te fais
un truc quand ouais c'est moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est bon je ne peux pas
expliquer quoi que à chaque fois que je
suis même aujourd'hui je reçois temporal
d'écouter le njawe new skies le grand
plaisir que j'ai eu puisque j'ai
tellement aimé effectivement en pension
à montlhéry
quand j'étais la nation et qui suit
c'est vrai mes pompes du matin parce que
parce que sinon on l'avait effectivement
les cool hein le premier jour j'ai
entendu ça c'était incroyable c'était un
son particulier cette pâle blues pas le
rock c'était un mec un génie un g1
génique et un jour à la fin des années
50 c'est ça que vous entendez
[Musique]
je
c'est trop beau dire c'est qu'aucun
cochrane qui m'a qui m'a et puis ensuite
qui a donné autre hogs visite le rock'n
roll a disparu en 59 avec l'aileron de
la cadillac xts à 39 eldorado salaire à
domont fallait des gros moyens en
principe ce qui est né dans la
différence entre une convertible toute
simple et une soixante de je veux dire
et puis une eldorado et puis là brougham
aussi alors c'est à cette époque
christophe que vous commencez à penser à
quitter juvisy sur orge pour la côte
d'azur vous commencez à fuguer
vous avez sur la côte d'azur en stop
ouais avec surtout d'une vie une guitare
un truc génial christophe c qui faisait
la manche en jouant dans les boîtes dans
les pizzas dawn of the rising sun vous
l'aviez entendu sur radio caroline
il disait aux gens c'est moi qu'il
l'écrit finalement personne d'autre le
connaissez j'écoutais radio carolin
effectivement depuis un an
ces marqueurs et gibbons puisse
l'acheter je la chantais bien parce que
j'ai parce que je l'aimais d'aviron sur
tech mais jamais puisque chanter du
blues surtout et quand j'avais 15 ans je
faisais la manche en chantant en ligne
c'est moi qui ai écrit c'est super ccc
mentir c'est celle imaginaire quand
c'est super de vêtements teurs vous faut
semer filtrer menteur un peu menteur un
menteur on va voir tout à l'heure alors
en 61 vous faites votre premier groupe
dehli baby et les hooligans ce vous
jouez le samedi dans des clubs à jouy en
josas et puis après le golf drouot eddie
barclay et vous sortez un quatre titres
et une chanson qui s'appelle reviens
sophie programmée par daniel filipacchi
pour vous le fait d'être programmé dans
salut les copains par daniel filipacchi
c'était mieux que devant des dix
finalement voici je suis pas tim aile
programme est donc une fois ouais
puisque j'étais face à france gall qui
gelait poupée de cire et donc fallait
que les gens choisissent c'est vrai que
nos choix était assez facile
ouais mais ce qui était important
effectivement c'était le son de la voix
de daniel filipacchi à lens en revient
sofia nouveau qui comme c'est comme
passer chez pivot pour un écrivain quoi
la consécration
ouais alors bon ça marche pas très bien
revient à sophie vous faites vous
retourner faire des études jusqu'au bepc
et là en 65 kg à sa gêne
décidée
sur le sable
son beau visage
[Musique]
qui ne sourit
puis il a plu
[Musique]
sur cette plage
cet orage
la spa
[Musique]
quarante ans après ça marche toujours
c'est incroyable énormément largué quand
même un premier titre revient à sophie
way après j'ai crié aline pour qu'elle
revienne mais j'ai vu de la gueule
c'était le premier devrait snow de l'été
à un million d'exemplaires
et puis voilà toujours vous serez
maintenant de toute façon l'auteur
d'aline alors c'est aline elle
s'appelait aline la tanovic 23 ans
allez la dame avait 23 ans assistante
d'un stomatologue vous l'avez revue
aline non non non non j'ai un bon
souvenir c'est effectivement cette
chanson qui commet qui pour moi reste la
plus belle
un bien joli à un mec qui lui demande
qui vous quelle est la plus belle
chanson du monde et retour à ligne par
christophe bien sûr mais contrairement
au jeune chanteur qui rogne et les
chansons l'an passé le voyez tout à fait
et le mec était un peu choqués vélib
attendait oui c'est ça pour moi c'est le
ménage chanson du monde ben ouais ouais
tu es caveau de famille à cette époque
là ils sont très contents c'est un
meilleur cadeau que le bepc faut bien le
dire
et puis mais faisait quand même des
problèmes d'adaptation dans le show
business à vous avez du mal à étudier
parce que vous avez le cheveu coup un
tee-shirt noir vous êtes à l'écart des
autres
vous prenez pas pour une vedette n'est
pas d'agencé pas de secrétaire
effectivement j'aime pas trop avoir
quelqu'un de toujours avec moi toujours
avec moi je suis j'aime bien pouvoir
être en suspension sur mon nuage d'or
dit non et puis voilà quoi
[Musique]
et là je vais
allez
qui sait
dumas pied
elle
sans joly
je vais
et voilà après service militaire dans
les paras bataillon disciplinaire et ça
vous a pas disciplinés du tout
d'ailleurs vous désertez vous retrouve
au val de grâce
hélas lors vous resté deux mois allongé
sur le lit en train de faire tomber des
cendres de cigarettes sur votre poitrine
comme ça quand on vous pose la question
vous dites c'est la seule sensation que
je puisse avoir
c'était effectivement une forme de 2,2
pas de pézilla mais d'être dans
lévitation un peu par rapport à la à
l'imaginaire qui travaille tout le temps
et cette réalité qui était là il est pas
mal vont se faire réformer sur la bbc
des réformes et blanc pris pour un
dingue et s'est fait fort mais là il a
tout fait pour ça mais ça tu vois un mec
dans la ligue qui se crame le torse avec
les clubs quand même qu'il y fut alors
lâché mais c'est ce qu'ils sont et
l'enlacé alors c'est quand même une
époque où sans devenir une une star yéyé
malgré tout vous conduisez vite vous
casser des bagnoles un jour vous avez
une lamborghini pas casser la
lamborghini quand même sur les
champs-elysées ouvriers deux feux rouges
vous rentrez dans une voiture de flics
devant le lido way
[Applaudissements]
bon j'ai signé mais surtout palmarès à
côté de moi qui qui lui est venue
beaucoup de moi j'ai comment je me
cachais gérants car je dois y aller à
l'essai jusqu'à ce jour rien pas même
pas de permis pendant pendant cinq ans 1
oui et là maintenant vous l'avez le
permis aujourd'hui la cour ce moment
nous non plus nova villa gillet champs
elysées après les chants voir ce que
j'ai fait un peu trop d'excès lui
demande excès de vitesse et puis j'ai
plus de points et puis je dois repasser
le le code voilà mais bon sang peut vous
aider que les soeurs moi c'est surtout
pour s'échapper
oui voilà après ça donc après aline
après les marionnettes quelques morceaux
vous disparaissez des hit parades et des
bacs à 10 vous quitter la scène y est
vous quittez votre appartement dans le
6e arrondissement
vous allez habiter à juvisy dont un
petit pavillon à côté de celui de vos
parents agitant fins l'école des filles
les affaires de pédophilie
on a dit qu'on n'en parlait pas de la
boulette
donc non la vous vantez des bagnoles
américaine et vous partez insensé cette
histoire avec le cirque gruss vous fait
cinq chansons par jour pour 500 francs
avec le cirque gruss vous jouer aux
boules avec zanatta vous commencez à
mener une vie comme c'est un peu comme
stéphanie de monaco maintenant
d'ailleurs elle avait que circus parlant
et non en est avec le cirque knie est
donc à trois mois pendant trois mois
trois mois vous rentrez dans la cage aux
lions avec arlette gruss chaque année et
même pas de photo d'ailleurs
alors quand vous partez du cirque gruss
on vous fait cadeau d'un million d'euros
et que vous baptisé christoph hein vous
le gardez avec vous comme ça pendant on
les chambres d'hôtel millions le matin
qu'ils essaient d'apporter le petit
déjeuner c'était l'enfer et puis un jour
vous le donner à un mac à nice qui
s'occupe des
la de l'étang qui qui qui est avec qui
avait des animaux voilà qui m'a dit
écoute on se rend compte comme ça et il
commence à devenir un petit peu le lion
quand j'étais attaché à la rochelle la
partie debout il commençait à une
chercheure il connaissait il était très
attaché et donc c'est cheap modibo il
sera bien à nice effectivement dans mon
dans mon espace et puis c'est comme ça
que j'ai réfléchi et j'ai dit oui je
veux pas l'homme est un jour christophe
ouvre le journal le wii wheel ouvre le
journal
et il voit marquer le lion christophe et
moore oui ah oui il ya une chanson là
dessus le lion christophe est mort
oui c'est vrai c'est de faire un
chapelet vous passez quelques années
comme ça on ne sait pas trop ce que vous
faites et en 73
vous rentrez chez les disques motors de
francis hélène dreyfus et là jean michel
jarre vous fait quelques jolis textes
parce que tout le monde croit qu'il a
fait les musiques en fête
il a fait les textes j'en ai fait déjà
les musiques c'est christophe et ça
donne ça
bondi la veille
on
[Musique]
il est
c'est midi
hier
il
[Musique]
soixante dix huit parole de bob decout
ma préférée
visiteurs
ce qu'on a
num
je
bon j'arrête parce que l'on pourra
écouter toute la nuit christophe parole
de bob decout un peu menteur élan vous
color me changer d'image là c'est à dire
que l'ex yéyé devient dandy vous avez un
public d'un seul coup beaucoup plus
intello et vous dites c'est vrai qu'à ce
moment là j'ai pris une façon
particulière de chanter parce que je
commençais à déchanter des choix et
c'est essayer de commande d'aller dans
afin d'aller comme ça spontanément dans
un acte un peu dans l'accident qui fait
qu'il ya toujours dans un la terre qui
penche pas toujours un peu dans la
déséquilibre dans la rondeur l'aï moi
même esthétique de la cour d'or line qui
qui qui donne vraiment une différence et
qui fait qu'il ya une émotion
particulière qui s'entend quoi c'est ce
que j'aime tendance dans ce que je dis
ce que j'écoutais ce que j'achète
et puis avec salon même album bizarre
[Musique]
mais ce dernier
mais lorsque son tour un ami un peu
passé
je vis de la vie christophe le mot
bizarre et puis alors après bizarrement
vous revenez après tous ces concepts
album vous revenez à des 45 tours qui
ont beaucoup de succès comme ça
[Musique]
chazal
et ça
[Musique]
ça
bakou
tu
vous dites je n'ai jamais considéré ce
qui m'arrivait en termes de carrière
j'ai toujours suivi mon instinct c'est
vrai oui il émotions l'instinct quand on
voit votre carrière là c'est très
chaotique en fait j'ai déjà dans un
style s'annonce à nouveau beaucoup at la
très bien ce que vous racontez mais ce
que j'aime analyser gym analyse très peu
quoi mais je préfère vivre que je suis
pas un carriériste quoi c'est pas mon
truc du tout quoi le jeune artiste si
c'est parce que ouais
peut-être je suis parti je suis chez moi
quoi je suis foutu sur ma route
vous savez qu'on ne bouge pas par jean
galle on vous l'a dit dans la bouche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quoi l'autre se croire ça qu'est ce qui
se passe mais je dois le public pourra
commencer à fait j'ai chirac dans le
public quand tu t'approches de sept cas
pas de culotte sur tout non non non non
elle est élue vous pensez à quoi là j'ai
toujours tendance à penser un petit peu
à la seconde qui bien je trouve que
c'est le plus beau moment de la miss et
c'est la seconde qu'il est déséquilibré
toujours vers la seconde suivante oui
quand vous vous regardez le matin dans
votre miroir vous vous dites quoi
j'aime bien non même avant d'ailleurs
j'aimais bien regarder dans les vitrines
ouais parce que il ya des villes et des
vitrines dans paris et des terroirs
qu'on connaît et je veux pas qu'on passe
ensemble
oui il ya des belleville oui un ailier
alias est un plaisir alors que tous les
matins quand même jour différent quand
j'ai l'habitude c'est chiant quand à
dire regardez tous les matins en haut
vous étiez petit bougnat semblait acquis
que la taille à qui marilyn monroe à
l'oubliette marilyn monroe
c'est pour ça les cheveux comme ça non
ces pétitions de cheveux c'est que gg
quand j'étais petit j'étais tellement
jamais tellement les photos de mariés
demande roger j'aimais tellement il est
vif les films que aujourd'hui si vous me
posez cette question j'ai pages est un
pur roman c'est ressembler marino droite
aurait aimé avoir des gros nation fait
aborder la latte et anciens ouais ouais
mais je suis pas homo non non juste je
veux des guerriers jour le terme on est
tous les mecs des promos du tout on a
bien qu'un tel système
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois l'impression de tout temps pleurer
mais enfin on fait comme les com mais
mais mais mes larmes ont couverts à
l'intérieur ça ne se voit pas à quoi
quel péché qui vous tente le plus
l'éclair au chocolat plus
ça c'est si c'était à refaire la vie
vous feriez quoi pas pareil je crois que
je crois que je ferais vraiment je vais
vraiment rêve le plus le plus le plus
profond c'est c'est le voilier donc je
crois que tout que très très tôt un
j'aurais appris très tôt à est ce qu est
ce qu ont peur et puis pour pouvoir me
away me barrer sur l'avenue antoine
peut-être pas vraiment ville et antoine
mais j'aurais plutôt envie une vitre à
coups de la tête pour lui voler son
bateau voilà quelle insulte qui vous a
fait le plus mal en toi qui viens de le
dire qu'elle est la dernière chose que
vous faites le soir avant de vous
coucher découpage vous est découpée quoi
par exemple cette semaine à cette
semaine voilà j'ai dit j'ai découvert ça
enfin cette semaine en deux soirs
ouais en gros je vois la découper sur
pen sur pen sean penn
ouais trucs sur en gros un morcellement
et des coloriages
[Rires]
ouais spip tintin plein plein de séjour
ce petit dossier comme ça vous avez
toujours avec vous c'est tout le temps
je veux revenir un truc c'est bien
puisque je fais souvent si bon c'est
j'ai toujours besoin d'une petite
friandise havre avant de m'endormir et
donc j'aime bien les sucettes au citron
ah bon c'est marrant c'est la dernière
personne que vous ayez envie de tuer
peut pas répondre à ta vais peut-être
antoine pour lui voler son bateau mais
ouais mais ouais mais c'est tout quoi je
vais dire ça fait deux fois qu'on dit
antoine chaînas l'air tu es ce que vous
avez déjà pensé au suicide que sauf ça a
dû dans mes rêves glacée de traverser
mais je pense que pour aller au bout je
pense qu'il faut être très fort à moi je
suis très faible
christophe est ce que vous avez menti
pendant cette interview bien sûr que oui
[Musique]